all right Julian Julian uh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally um
I I was born in Washington you see I
grew up in the San Fernando Valley
though in the van eyes um Panorama City
area tell me about your family grown up
you had Mom and Dad um it was just me my
mom and my sister uh growing up we uh my
mom was a single mother she is an artist
and she struggled but she did anything
and everything she had to do to to make
sure that me and my sister had what we
needed um how would you how would you
describe your childhood in
general uh
hectic one word hectic but uh it was uh
it was I I I I I had no idea that it was
any different but it but really it was
pretty different than than the average
person in what ways um well I had I I I
really grew up on like two sides of the
of the spectrum I grew up uh in uh my
neighborhood which was really poor and
uh with uh around around gangs and uh
drugs and uh on that level and then uh I
grew up in uh around uh Rich Jewish kids
and and like un famous people's kids
from where I went to school um because I
I was a like I guess a um tested gifted
when I was when I was young and they so
they put me in like a a higher higher
level of schooling uh and where there
was a lot of uh a lot of uh more just
there were white kids white kids uh and
and famous kids and uh kids with money
you know how how were your high school
years uh my high school years were were
pretty were fun you know I mean I was in
and at of jun Hall yeah but um but I
also I made a lot of money I got I
helped my mom I got I helped my mom uh
when she could was having hard times and
I
um I had I partied a lot I got I i' met
uh some I met my Idols um in my high
school years I um got hung out backstage
with the Red Hot Chili Peppers which was
like my like the coolest thing I could
have ever asked for um just uh and um
and
I and I got put onto a dark path as well
though you know I got yeah I got
I learned all about drugs and and and
that lifestyle and and I learned that
and I I idolized that that lifestyle did
did the drugs come from being in the
rougher neighborhood or come from the
the wealthier crowd they both they
started they started from the the
rougher neighborhood and uh being put
pressed to to sell them to bring them to
the to the wealthier crowd you know oh
cuz you were white yeah I was white and
I was uh and I was good at talking to
people and people liked me
the community you you grew up in was
mostly Mexican or black Hispanic yeah
Hispanic yeah so you were the white kid
that could make the connections exactly
exctly and then and then the rich crowd
in the rich crowd I was the I was the uh
con yeah basically yeah I was the plug I
was also like the the they felt they
felt they knew I was poor and they
wanted a lot of people like they like
all my like my friends my friend's
parents would uh would
were like I had so many so many second
parents because they all knew that my
mom's situation and that she was
struggling they they I could I was and I
was really good at talking to my to the
to the other parents you know so I and
they all loved me I would I had I could
go to so all my different homes and get
uh get taken care of you know and get
what I whatever I needed that I couldn't
get at
home and and the the the Rich and Famous
that you would be mingling with were
from what industries like movies my my
dad see my dad also does spe does
special effects and uh he has a lot of
connections he he didn't necessarily
make it big in that world but um he had
a lot of connections in that world uh
and like again like I said I was good at
talking to people and people liked me I
I uh got myself an internship when I was
young where uh do working on um in the
doing music videos uh uh with uh some
like pretty some pretty big like metal
bands and stuff um and uh just as like a
little as a young little gopher running
around doing you can name drop a little
bit if you want um like uh so we we made
slip knots masks we made we did uh all
of Aussie Osborne's music videos all of
a um System of Down stuff M&M's we made
the head the the the severed head for
Miss Elliot's one minute man um we made
we did uh photo shoots for Eminem we did
except for corn uh we I mean all the all
the metal bands really was what the the
company was called screaming mad Georgia
special effects and he was it was a
Japanese guy that owned it and he uh and
he was really good at what he did and
really big in that world actually you
told me a fun story outside about uh
your your friend when you were younger
yeah so um one of my uh one of my very
close friends was uh uh was is the son
of the guitar player for Tom pedy the
Heartbreakers Mike Campbell's a guitar
player um and my friend was Daren
Campbell he uh and we uh we got strung
out on coke together when we were young
and uh and we start and we to support
our habit we were stealing his his dad's
guitars his dad had thousands of guitars
mind you but we're stealing his his
dad's guitars and going and pawning them
for next to nothing which was so stupid
too but uh to to support our habit and
uh eventually uh it came out of the
closet and we ended up having to go and
track down do everything we can to track
down all the guitars we got back all all
like 14 of them except for one um and
his I me mind you his Dad paid a lot of
money to get them back as well but um
yeah we tracked them down and uh and we
uh and we definitely uh were were made
to not do that again you you know but uh
but but ALS but that being said yeah um
I grew up with with Daren the second
joint I ever smoked was with Tom Petty
um which was which was amazing I mean I
I I've sat there I've sat in in Mike's
living room on mushrooms just tripping
balls talking and talking talking to
Mike and and and Tom for I I'm pretty
sure it was hours but who knows how long
it was I was tripping balls about life
and stuff and uh and just different
stuff I I you know I used to I used to
be at his house all the time and his dad
Mike used to have he had pet pigs and he
had like a pig pen they love animals
they have his his mom owns a um a
grooming company in Burbank uh called
The bowow Bungalow um that a lot of us
used to work at actually also when we
were in high school but um but yeah they
love anim was and Mike had pet pigs and
he would wrestle them he would just like
literally jump in the mud and start
wrestling them it was it was hilarious
um he he loved those pigs yeah um what
what
insights did did you gain from seeing
the drug involvement of the really poor
communities and then the drug use
amongst the uh the the wealthy and the
famous um what insights uh is it just is
basically just the same thing it's the
same thing people love drugs yeah people
love Dr it's CRA I mean it is it is
crazy like the in the the um the
different ends of the spectrum though
like in one on in the in the wealthy
community it's like it's not it's like a
it's all fun in games you know um in the
in the poor Community it's all business
you know and uh and I and like I've seen
some crazy [__] on that end too I've
seen people get killed I've seen um you
know I've I've come across dead bodies
and um
I've uh seen like my share I I I I have
a hard time sleeping at night I can say
that much you know like just from a lot
of the things I've seen some things that
I've that I felt I needed to do as well
you know that haunt me
still yeah the streets are rough yeah
how old are you now uh
34 34 if if you had your life to live
all over again what would you have done
differently
um because you're still you're still on
the streets and using yeah I mean I'm
yeah I I would have uh I wouldn't have
done much differently except for the
drug use I would have still sold the
drugs I would have done all that I would
honestly because but I would have uh the
the big the worst thing I did was I got
was getting strung out I got addicted to
heroin when I was 14 and I I wish I
would have never tried it so young I at
the age I tried it I didn't understand
that I
didn't understand what it meant to be
uh I didn't I didn't understand the the
seriousness of it you know so I I didn't
understand I I want this first time I
tried it I I in my head I was going to
do it every day for the rest of my life
I loved it you know um if I would have
been a little bit older one when I tried
it I would have understood that uh
something that good needs to be
respected you know and needs to be uh
and there and therefore like needs and
should be uh Limited at least to if if
you uh want to enjoy it you know would
would you have been able
to make the connections in the upper
class neighborhoods or the or even on
the streets in the in the rougher
neighborhood that you grew up in if you
were not involved in drugs if I wasn't
involved in if I wasn't if you were just
totally a square clean kid absolutely
not absolutely not but if I would have
not used the drugs then I would have
gone a lot farther and I would have not
done a lot more and but then again who
knows I'd also could have probably been
like federal prison if I that in that
case too you know something you know
like but I I definitely uh once I once I
started using the drugs the the people
that I really respected in in the drug
dealing world uh the higher ups they uh
definitely started to look down on me a
lot more you know and didn't and stop
and didn't want to like have me do as
much as I would have liked to do you
know and you're today you're homeless uh
I'm today I'm homeless yeah you just
where do you you have a tent here or um
I I stay I stay at friends houses and
stuff I I don't want to get it I've been
I I was stay I've had my own place since
my mom kicked me out when I was 15 I've
had my own place on my and um been able
to managed that up until about 2 years
ago and um and I I I don't I refuse to
get a tent because I don't want to
accept that um the homelessness I'm I
refuse to do that like I'm I'm I'm going
to work probably my way out standards
yeah yeah I'm prob my way out of this
I'm not going to let myself what is your
drug today um B all and
crack
yeah yeah which is basically just a
speedball
I mean yeah before it was Fenton crack I
used to shoot heroin and and cocaine uh
and I stopped doing that because that my
veins got real bad you know fentanyl was
a viable option to keep me well without
without shooting a heroin cuz it got me
high from smoking it eventually but
eventually I missed the cocaine high as
well so I started smoking crack with it
and it's yeah exactly it's a speed ball
I love speed balls I love they're
[__] it's the best feeling it there
is so the the
heroin makes you forget about anything
you're dealing with emotionally the more
fent the the fenyl the fenyl makes me
puts me to sleep and or and the but and
the crack makes me uh not
care you know the heroin the heroin will
can will put me to sleep when I and yeah
the crack makes me not care have you
been clean before yeah I've I've had
time cleaning I've like been uh worked
in the rehab and [__] for a little
while tell me about your jewelry on your
left
ankle yeah um I just got I got just got
out of jail a few days ago um other than
juvenal I haven't really done a lot of
time but um I guess for some reason they
felt that
uh that um they needed to make sure that
I they knew where I was I guess until I
until I'm done doing what they want me
to do for court I
um it's
a I got uh typically isn't it sex
offenders that typically get a ankle
monitor oh I I get know I get if people
that they're concerned aren't going to
show up for court or people that are
concerned are going to flee oh I see
yeah then I can't really talk about what
I got arrested for too much it's because
um people the people that I work with
don't
really yeah but um what's your greatest
fear now at this point in your
life um not not have not getting my [__]
together not having eventually I'd like
to have a family you know I've always
wanted to have a family I I I'm at the
point where I I'm I want to turn [__]
around a little bit you know and uh I
want to find somebody
that uh that can put up with me I can
put up with them you know
well I mean what you're the baggage
you're carrying is going to require
somebody who's very forgiving yeah EXA
definitely unless you get clean or
understanding yeah yeah yeah no I mean I
don't and and getting clean getting
clean is also is is not is is not out
for the past 12 years i' I would I
hadn't I you couldn't you wouldn't catch
me saying that I that I was can I get I
get clean or that it was even an option
in my head but um I'm starting to get
I'm starting to get kind of tired you
know starting to get feel like I need
a feel like I deserve something else a
little bit even you know yeah life is
passing you by
yeah what's your greatest
strength um my heart you know I
I anybody and everybody that knows me
knows that like uh I I look out for
everybody I do it all and I I care and I
I
I work my ass off to I work my ass off
every day to make to make sure that I
that I'm that I'm I have what I need and
that whoever's around me has what they
need too um which is probably also a
little bit of a of a um uh defect as
well because I I tend to look out for
more people than I should you know when
I could be putting that energy into
something else
but um but
yeah I'm I'm always uh
I'm always looking out for people in one
way or
another what's the craziest thing you've
seen in all your years of this life that
revolves around drugs craziest thing
I've seen like the uh I mean there's
what area like the most dangerous or
like scary thing or either one you it
sounds like you've seen both ends of the
spectrum yeah I mean I've seen I've
walked in on on on a into a a house with
like dead bodies in them in it you know
that had been there for for for a couple
days you could smell it outside of the
house you know um
and uh and that was at a young age too
you know but among amongst the the
wealthy F families that you knew as a
kid yeah how often were drugs involved
in those oh families always really
always always I mean one way or another
yeah I
mean
yeah boys pretty
much in the in the other end of the
spectrum like the craziest thing I've
flown in a helicopter into uh into a
[__] into uh the San Francis San
Francisco Sports Arena to and uh to the
to the backstage of a um Tom Petty
concert it's pretty fun yeah like that's
just flying in helicopter in general
most people haven't like even done that
but yeah yeah I mean rest in peace D
Petty he's and what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your
life
um just
to that whatever's happeneds happened
and can't live for yesterday or
tomorrow yeah excellent all right Julian
thank you so much for sharing your story
yeah thank you
thanks